the crowded theatrical release calendar
of 2020 was bound to produce box-office
disappointments some are massive star
packed tentpole films that audiences
weren't interested in others are smaller
films with bad word of mouth however
they got here these are the biggest
flops of 2020 so far
sometimes the film just doesn't land
even when it has its defenders that was
the case with underwater the Kristen
Stewart led sci-fi horror film that was
presented as a kind of creature feature
throwback movie in the vein of films
like alien and the abyss the film
arrived at a slow time for films anyway
in early January and while it certainly
had its fair share of critical fans
early on a garnered mixed reviews then
audiences just didn't seem to want to
show up and a/c CinemaScore on opening
weekend didn't help with that to the
bottom of the ocean and we don't know
underwater picked up just seven million
dollars in the US on its opening weekend
on its way to a domestic total of 17
point 2 million dollars the film did
better internationally grossing 23.5
million in various territories around
the world the eventual total as of
mid-march is just over 40 million
dollars a lot of modestly priced horror
films would love to have a worldwide
total like that but underwater wasn't
modestly priced it's reported budget was
closer to sixty million dollars thanks
to its effects heavy production and that
meant the box office was significantly
underwhelming Doolittle an adaptation of
Hugh loftiness Doctor Dolittle stories
was Robert Downey jr. 'he's first major
project since his exit from the ultra
profitable Marvel Cinematic Universe
reigned over for more than a decade it
was a longtime passion project of
Downey's a film packed with stars in its
hoist cast and an attempt for the MCU
Godfather to use his cloud to deliver
some magical family fun at the box
office
unfortunately Doolittle was a troubled
production as various rewrites and
reshoots led to the budget swelling to a
massive 175 million dollars that made it
tough to recoup costs in the first place
but that audiences just didn't seem to
want to show up for the film and critics
savaged in Downey's first major post
Marvel tentpole deflated rapidly and
while there was some hope that it could
gain some ground in China the corona
virus outbreak there led to its release
getting canceled do a little bottom down
at about two hundred and twenty three
point three million dollars worldwide
which was likely not enough to earn back
the cost of promoting and
juicing film horror films are often
protected from box office disaster in a
way that other films aren't for one
thing there are a lot of people who just
like to see whatever the latest horror
film is regardless of what critics might
say about it
for another horror films are usually at
least relatively cheap to make put out a
film that costs 10 million dollars
earned 40 million dollars worldwide turn
a profit and move on then there are
those films that just can't quite
overcome lackluster marketing and poor
word-of-mouth response like attorney use
your friends must love it here I have no
friends you have no friends yep well you
have one now maybe this modern-day
retelling of Henry James's turn of the
screw was perhaps fighting an uphill
battle to begin with thanks to his
January release date and push backs on
the release calendar then came the early
response critics didn't like the film
and audiences didn't respond to it
either the turning in part because of
its disappointing ending earned a rare F
cinema score grade on its opening
weekend and everyone pretty much stayed
away after that on a budget of 14
million dollars the Pillman's aren't
just 18 point four million dollars
worldwide the rhythm section a Blake
Lively led revenge thriller in the vein
of films like taken seem to have the
potential to be a new badass
female-driven action hit the key word
there is scene because the reality of
the film's release ultimately spelled
one of the worst box-office duds ever
recorded
with a number of contributing factors
the film opened at the end of January
and grossed just 2.7 million dollars
domestically in its first weekend that's
the lowest box-office haul for a film
opening in more than 3,000 theaters ever
and one of the lowest openings of all
time for a major studio release so what
went wrong
according to Deadline it began with
lackluster test screenings that
basically convinced the executives at
Paramount that the film wasn't worth
pouring a ton of marketing money into
add in a lackluster critical response
and an opening weekend CinemaScore fc+
and it was a film that had no real buzz
and no word of mouth to speak up
the film's lukewarm domestic performance
meant that it barely got an
international release at all and the box
office total came to just 5.9 million
dollars
losing upwards of 30 million dollars
while it may seem like they ruled the
box office every year thanks to
everything from superhero tentpoles the
live-action remakes of animated
six even Disney produces a bomb now in
that their latest major box-office
disappointment which the studio
inherited in their purchase of Fox came
in the form of the call of the wild
Harrison Ford led adaptation of Jack
London's novel that became known rather
quickly as that movie where Harrison
Ford hangs out with a CGI dog
[Music]
that's mine hey thanks
the film's decision to use a motion
captured CGI dog to play ports canine
companion rather than a real trained
animal helped us well the film's budget
to a hefty 135 million dollars that's a
steep box-office hill to climb and
audiences didn't seem ready to help the
film reach the summit the call of the
wild pulled in less than 25 million
dollars domestically in its opening
weekend for a worldwide total of 107
point 5 million dollars as of mid March
in March 2020 box-office experts
estimated that the film could end up
losing as much as 50 million dollars
even under normal circumstances some
films just don't do well at the box
office by the middle of March 2020
though it became clear that movies this
year would be dealing with anything but
normal circumstances as the corona virus
pandemic swept across the world movie
studios and theater chains had to make
some difficult decisions releases were
delayed indefinitely while theaters
began closing to limit the spread of the
virus while several upcoming
blockbusters had their release dates
postponed to wait for a more opportune
time a few films already in theaters had
their box office run severely shortened
onward Pixar's latest major release and
a solid week or so on screens pulling in
a hundred and 2.7 million dollars
worldwide not bad for a start but still
well short of the total the studio may
have hoped for
meanwhile Sony's superhero adventure
bloodshot managed twenty four point two
million dollars after a March 13th
opening at a time when many people were
already avoiding crowded theaters
then there's the hunt a film that had
already been delayed once which pulled
in just six point three million dollars
after its own March 13th opening well
below its budget it's possible that
future theatrical time or home releases
can help Studios gain some ground on
these films but again it's just a case
of bad timing we may never know how high
any of these films might have actually
climbed check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]